attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
il vraiment pas bon tant qu'à faire on
se fait chier la rente soit on fait un
truc ça je me barre et les cas on peut
faire un jeu ah oui génial franchement
c'est ma meilleure soirée depuis le
début de l'année dont on va manger des
bolognaise on va faire un jeu de merde
sa meilleure soirée de l'année bah ouais
sauf que y'avait pas ma femme je peux
pas changer le monde
on c'est cool on fait quoi un monopoly
on peut faire un monopoly ou un truc
c'est que moi je suis toujours la banque
donc je souffre des billets en secrète
donc je triche qua non sinon on fait un
loup garou non louga où c'est chiant
mais deux heures expliqué le jeu
personnel mêmes règles et ça finit
toujours en embrouille
sinon moi j'ai un jeu c'est la bahia
c'est quoi les règles y a pas de règle
je me lève et pendant un quart d'heure
je tartine la gueule et pim épi et pis
c'est chaude et donc toi tu dis que le
gillain le valais ouais il est moins
forte la dame au poker oui mais comme
dans beaucoup de jeux de cartes
d'ailleurs je me demande où 500 tu veux
le futur tête des cas de merde
ah oui j'ai un jeu de merde u17 et en
deux mais je savais donc pour moi c'est
tapis allait surtout mieux qu'une paire
de dames toi alors ok bim all in
bravo à moi je me couche voilà encore de
20 merci monsieur distributeurs ouais je
me sens moins tient à votre texas là
[Musique]
est ce que ton personnage a des lunettes
non il a des cheveux longs à bout qu'il
est roux c'est bernard non c'est alfred
c'est alfred oui bah ouais ouais moi
c'était victor
[Musique]